for the last I don't know year or more
we followed Rudy Giuliani's constant
missteps as Donald Trump's public
attorney he would show up and say oh the
quote that I attributed to the president
was a hypothetical quote or I'm still
getting up to speed on things or this
thing never happened never never it
never happened and then all of a sudden
he says well yeah of course it happened
but it's not a crime and after these
constant missteps we saw Rudy pulled
from public media appearances he
completely disappeared from television
in his role as a defender of Donald
Trump for months and we actually
addressed that during audience questions
a couple of weeks ago Rudy Giuliani has
now DITA reappeared apparently once at
the bar report came out once william
bars summary of robert Muller's summary
of molars investigation once that came
out maybe the Trump people felt that
Rudy would not be able to do more damage
now that Trump has been quote exonerated
so Monday night Rudy Giuliani shows up
at Fox News he appears on the Sean
Hannity program and he bizarrely
out-of-left-field
claims that Robert Muller was paid
thirty million dollars to run the Russia
investigation which is obviously untrue
but it's also ridiculous like anyone who
knows what federal government jobs pay
would immediately recognize that thirty
million dollars for two years the only
way you're getting thirty million in two
years out of the federal government is
if you're a weapons contractor selling
the missiles that can be used to kill
people overseas you're not getting
thirty million by running an
investigation that's for sure in any
case here is Rudy Giuliani making the
claim to Sean Hannity and of course
Hannity not refuting it then bar and
Rosenstein kind of knocked the
obstruction thing right out of the park
no ma let's hand it back to Rosenstein
and because the guy the guy got paid
somewhere upwards of thirty million
dollars but he couldn't make the key
decision his hands were shaking he
probably had you know he had Jekyll and
Hyde he had
guys and the good guys so reports her
that molars salary was a hundred and
sixty-two thousand dollars per year
based on the federal government schedule
of salaries that he would be entitled to
based on experience but Rudy makes the
claim and Hannity doesn't correct him
and it you know what is true is that
Robert Muller was reportedly making more
than three million dollars at the DC law
firm that he left in order to run this
probe which is which is pretty
interesting and this is how the circle
of BS goes okay Rudy says it Sean
Hannity doesn't refute it and now Trump
or whoever can say people say Muller was
paid thirty million dollars to do this
thing which is of course ridiculous
Donald Trump is President of the United
States he can find out how much Robert
Muller was actually paid by the federal
government but it perpetuates the circle
of disinformation they'll then imply
that the thirty million dollars was some
kind of a bribe so that Muller would
come to some particular conclusion which
of course if true has completely
backfired
since Muller punted to William Barr at
least on the issue of obstruction of
justice by Donald Trump so what what's
missing in terms of the finances of this
investigation is that the costs of the
investigation do appear to have been
about twenty million dollars I have no
particular reason to not believe that
but the investigation has recovered more
than forty million dollars in other
words the investigation made money the
investigation ran a surplus which we
can't say about Donald Trump's federal
government despite the numerous promises
that he made so bottom line I see this
Pat as indicative that people on the
Trump side are still very worried about
the contents of the report so they have
to continue to malign Robert Muller
because remember molar could not
exonerate Trump from obstruction
remember all we have is a political
summary of a summary and if this were
really the end they wouldn't still be
going out there and attacking and
smearing Robert Muller well first of all
I think it's good to see Rudy Giuliani
out of detention because
I think he was producing a segment for
us just about every week so good to have
him back also even if the investigation
did cost twenty million dollars and
there wasn't anything recovered from it
that would be totally fine as an
investment like the federal budget each
year is about three trillion dollars
usually when we talk about government
expenditures we're talking about
something in the neighborhood of
billions of dollars 20 million dollars
for a two-year investigation that's just
a drop in the bucket yeah and what's
important to mention also is that a lot
of the people that were working all so
Pat makes a good point which is if
crimes have taken place and you get 37
indictments and people are held
accountable for things that they did you
don't have to turn a profit on the
investigation right government doesn't
have to turn a profit on everything it
does this is sort of like you know we do
we not want police investigating murders
if those investigations aren't going to
be profitable no of course not if
wrongdoing has taken place it should be
done anyway but there's a really
additional good point to make about the
cost of the investigation part of what's
being included in that cost are the
salaries of people working in the
investigation a lot of those people
would be working earning similar or
identical salaries just in other
departments so they're not even it's not
even new spending and I don't even know
if it's worth going into this because
the right just doesn't care right I mean
that they'll use anything to say the
investigation was a sham or a farce or
witch-hunt but this is also just moving
around money that a lot of those
investigators would have made anyway
just from other departments I guess we
don't even really need to go into it too
much further but a key point that I do
want to make here you simultaneously
have people who are claiming that the
investigation was a sham from the get-go
but that Muller's conclusions as
summarized by William Barr are accurate
and believable so let me kind of go into
detail about what I mean by that but
you've had people on the right who have
said from the beginning molars
appointment was illegal the entire thing
is a political witch-hunt Muller can't
be trusted Mulder should be fired the
investigation is filled with anti-trump
democrats Muller was paid 30 million to
run the investigation
Moeller
had it in for Trump molars a partisan
actor who is discredited and dishonest
but then all of a sudden when William
bar says here's my summary of the work
that Muller did they accept it they
accept Muller's conclusion as summarized
by William Barr that there was no
collusion they accept William bars
conclusion that on the basis of molars
probe it doesn't make sense to charge
Trump with obstruction which by the way
is not what Muller said it's what Barr
has decided to do
how can you simultaneously have maligned
molars investigation for two years in
every way shape and form but now say
here's what Muller says happened and we
completely trust it
synthesized of course through William
bars political lens doesn't really make
sense your your partisanship is showing
very very clearly today's program is
sponsored in part by control center by
kaavo which simplifies your home theater
so you can control everything that's
connected to your TV with a single
easy-to-use remote with voice control
you can plug in your streamer your sound
system cable or satellite even your game
console and Control Center will do it
all no fiddling with multiple remotes
dropping them and having batteries go
all over the floor and underneath the
couch speaking from personal experience
one universal voice remote controls it
all say what you want to watch and
Control Center will handle the rest I
set it up with my TV sound system and
DVD player and it is really simplified
everything SHOP NOW get 40% off control
center with promo code Pakman that's
59.95 40% off the regular price of 99.95
service plan required first 45 days are
free control center is available at CAA
veoh.com
and best buy control center by kaavo one
remote that does it all